in that old argument about which job is
the biggest challenge to writers an
original screenplay or one based on
other material I'm not afraid to admit
that I don't know all I know is that we
can't film anything without a screenplay
and the best of the five originators of
5 originals nominated this year from
screenwriters who should know John Logan
for The Aviator Charlie Kaufman Michel
Gondry and Pierre bismuth for Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind gia
Pearson and Terry George for Hotel
Rwanda Brad Bird will be Incredibles
likely reviewer drink and the Oscar goes
to Charlie Kaufman Michel Gondry he had
this loop for Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind
this is the first Academy Award for
Charlie Kaufman Michel Gondry and Pierre
bismuth Charlie Kaufman was previously
nominated for writing adaptation and
Being John Malkovich
thanks to the Academy 29 seconds 27
seconds that's really intimidating I try
to look somewhere else there's so many
people work so creatively on this movie
and so I feel like this award is for all
of them and most especially want to
thank Kate Winslet and Jim Carrey and
director Michelle gondry and producers
Anthony Bregman and Steve :
and I'm supposed to wrap up now and you
know I don't want to take my time I want
to get off the stage
so thank you hi to my daughter Anna